[Musique]
alors il ya beaucoup d'animaux à la
espère en particulier d'été
[Musique]
là on est en pleine période de
déménagement départs en vacances les
gens ne savent pas quoi faire de leur
animal donc ils viennent de déposer à la
spa où la tâche on a forest lait sur la
voie publique
mais on a aussi forcément la période des
chaleurs des chattes qui se sont
produites quelques semaines auparavant
et chatons mis bas il ya les chatons de
partout ça pulse asseoir des buissons
tous nous en dépose donc
donc voilà pourquoi on est on est à des
nombres comme ça c'est important
[Musique]
alors il ya des solutions effectivement
déjà de la stérilisation des animaux en
tous les animaux partie stériliser du
refuge parce qu'on n'a pas envie qui est
de la reproduction est la sauvage évitez
aussi que les sites internet proposent
des solutions des changes de vente
d'animaux tout le monde vante son petit
chien son petit chat sur internet à des
gens qui ne connaissent pas et du coup
les gens dépassés viennent déposer à la
spa tout simplement c'est le vraiment le
sav de tous ces sites internet où on
peut échanger la marchandise
[Musique]
mieux venir directement à la spa faut
pas non plus s'y prendre à la dernière
minute deux mois avant on prend les
informations on prendre rendez vous et
on abandonne abandonne son animal il ya
un moment donné où nous aussi on a
besoin afin de faire de la place pour
pouvoir faire entrer des animaux faire
de la place pour nous ça signifie pas
faire d adoption faire des transferts
d'animaux il n'y a pas doute and asia
lesbiens quand un animal reste trop
longtemps au refuge
on va le transférer dans un autre refuge
parce que s'ils en échec d'adoption ici
sera peut-être pas un échec d'adoption
dans un refuge de province
[Musique]
juin juillet août on a plus de place et
les gens continuent à venir en disant je
pars en vacances mais si on n'a pas de
place on ne prend pas en fait le chat
mais du coup l'animal va la fourrière
animale et en fourrière animale ils
risquent de canadiens la fourrière
animale n'est pas là pour regarder les
animes autant qu'ils ont de la place il
le faut à un moment donné quand ya plus
de place il faut en faire je souligne en
fourrière animale je veux vraiment pas
qu'on mélange fourrière animale et
respect
[Musique]